and we are now joined by magnus carlsen
after
three wins today and minus how happy are
you with your end game
play in this last game
oh uh well i think it was okay apart
from
from one moment when i i went c
c three there and weakened my my pawn um
i should have just taken a little bit of
time
at that point because the position was
obviously winning
and all the work was was done uh but
uh yeah after after i made that one
careless move
um you could set up a defense
uh which was uh uh yeah quite
unfortunate uh but yeah i managed to
manage to escape somehow i just moved
around
and eventually short of time he he uh
he messed up um which is the way it
often
often goes like uh the dream of uh
uh playing sort of a model game usually
goes out the window and then you
you end up uh hustling your way to to
victory instead
well magnus overall a very good day for
you i mean three wins
in the five first rounds also then a
loss against the niche so i'm wondering
what are you most happy about today and
what are you most
annoyed about
oh i'm quite happy with the way i
converted the first game against uh
jordan um then i guess i played a little
bit too
carelessly against danish i think it was
claire from from the opening that i had
no
no problems but then i sort of
had an idea to play ambitiously by
uh by breaking up the pawn structure and
potentially giving me
some the antigen that in the center but
then yeah it didn't didn't work
out at all and i think uh he did
quite quite nicely there um
apart from that i'm just happy to get
going i don't think i played
particularly well but the score is
square is very good
and most important thing is
to not mess up on the first day and that
i think i did
and some more magnus
yeah we must uh admit we really like the
vest here in the studio have you been
playing some snooker today
no i ha i have not uh
i only had the vest once before uh
really at the i think the press
conference of uh
uh of the the
my first world championship match um and
i don't know why
it's been gone for so long but it's not
now it's back and
probably to stay ah nice
all right and well magnus looking
entertaining and
also i want to ask you about that game
against mcsim
that first move i think it was uh the c
pawn
one square uh very strange for us
what was that all about yeah that was a
mouse loop
who was it yeah
i mean i was just a bit too
too casual there but
if you're going to mouse sleep it's
better to do it on the
on the first move after all there are
there aren't many
too bad moves you can you can make uh
and
it certainly made the game interesting
after his his response so
i i was not too
neither too upset nor too too worried to
be
to be fair hmm well we did have peter
haina
uh joining us after that game and he
didn't want to give away
if that was actually something you were
working on so are you happy with your
partner in crime there
no i
commend him for always being being
professional
um but the thing is
i don't think there are any advantages
to playing c3
over let's say d4 or d5 or knight f6
c3 uh it really only gives black
good options like playing e5 for
instance
uh i was thinking after e5 maybe i'd go
see foreign players
um but uh as i said
it's uh it's a good kind of message
okay well david here was uh applauding
you a lot for that move because it
seemed to get maxim out of
his move order he loves his move order
and his opening so
can this be the recipe against players
like maxim
i think when he goes
1b6 he gives me sort of a second
chance to to put upon pawn on e4
so i i i i grabbed that one
um it's interesting because one b3 is
the series
or at least half series opening as white
and i wonder if putting my phone on c3
there
uh is actually detrimental to
uh to my position or just
more or less um
yeah more or less even um it's hard to
say
uh anyway as you said it led to a very
interesting
uh fight so i think neither
neither i nor him could uh particularly
complain about that
yeah magnus uh you've proved me wrong i
thought you were just trying to be
honorable and not force maxim to kind of
show his preparation before the
candidates
i think c4 would be part of that as well
that would do that would do the job
without uh
without losing a tempo on the first move
all right well minus we're hoping and
looking forward to more surprises and
entertainment tomorrow thank you for
joining us thank you